in this video we're going to get a
little bit of practice estimating with
multiplication so over here it says
question mark is and then you have the
squiggly equal sign and so you could
view that squiggly equal sign as being
what is this roughly equal to it doesn't
have to be exactly right so what is
roughly equal to 58 times six and so
which of these choices would you pick
pause the video and see if you can
answer that so once again we don't have
to get this exactly
we just need to estimate what 58 times
six is and the way that I would tackle
it is hey can i rewrite 58 as a number
that it's easy to multiply by six or
easy to multiply in general and the
easiest thing I can think of is 58 is
awfully close to 60 so if you say that
that is close to 60 if we're just
estimating it well what would 60 times
six be well 60 times six is the same
thing as actually let me just write it
this way you could view 60 times six as
six times 10 times six which you could
also view as six times six times ten and
what's 6 times 6 that's 36 and then 36
times 10 is 360 so I would go with that
choice right over there notice these
other choices aren't even aren't
anywhere close to that so we feel pretty
good about our estimation let's do
another example
so here it's where I asked what's 3
times 2,890 what's that roughly equal to
how would you estimate this pause the
video and see if you can figure that out
all right so 2,890 is not an easy thing
to maybe multiply in our heads but I
could say hey that's kind of close to
3,000 so I'm gonna say that this is
going to be so it's going to be
approximately equal to or roughly equal
to 3 times 3,000 now what's 3 times 3
that's 9 so it's 3 times 3,000 well it's
going to be 9 thousands and so it would
be this choice right over there here's
what I just did was a little bit
confusing you could view 3 times 3000 as
3 times 3 times a thousand this part
right over there is 3000
three times three is the nine and you
have 9,000 9,000 let's do one more
example this is going to involve fairly
large numbers so what is if you have to
estimate 5111 times nine which of these
would you pick pause the video and
answer that all right so I would view
this this is roughly I would estimate it
as 5,000 times nine and so 5,000 times
nine that's the same thing as five times
a thousand times nine which is the same
thing as five times nine times a
thousand five times nine is forty-five
so it's gonna be 45 thousands or forty
five thousand which is this choice right
over there